INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON THE
TRIBAL STATE COMPACT BETWEEN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN THE
PICAYUNE RANCHERIA. FOR THOSE
OF YOU UNFAMILIAR WITH THE
SERVICE PROCEDURE THE
ESTABLISHED POLICY ALLOWS FOR
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS ON THE
DETAILS OF THE COMPACT TO BE
FOLLOWED BY A VOTE ON THE
SENATE FLOOR. NO VOTE WILL BE
TAKEN HERE TODAY. THE VEHICLE
FOR RATIFICATION FOR THESE
CONTACTS WILL BE MY OWN BILL SB
THREE OH TWO. IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT ALL THE
COMPACT'S MIRROR MANY OF THE
RECENT COMPACTS THAT HAVE COME
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE. THIS
INCLUDES ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION LANGUAGE LABOR
PROVISIONS THAT ALLOW WORKERS
TO UNIONIZE PROVISIONS THAT
ALLOW FOR OFF RESERVATION
MITIGATION AND LANGUAGE THAT
ESTABLISHES A PROCESS IT
FOCUSES BUTTE WERE TO ARISE.
FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. ONE
EIGHT SEVEN SIX ONE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. THREE THREE SIX FOUR
FOUR THREE SEVEN. AND THAT
ACCESS CODE IS EIGHT TWO SIX.
EIGHT FOUR TWO EIGHT. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
USE A TELECONFERENCE IS DONE
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
INDOOR COMMITTEE WEBSITE WE'LL
BEGIN WITH NATHAN. LOCALITY IN
OREM TRIBAL NEGOTIATIONS
ADVISER FOR GOVERNOR NEWSOM I
UNDERSTAND HE IS ON ZUMIEZ FROM
A GALLEY- PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
BEGIN. THANK YOU JERRY DON GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MAKING
VOCALLY AND I'M INTER I'M
TRAVELING- SHE SHINS ADVISER
FOR THE GOVERNOR FILLING IN FOR
ANNA NAME MARK. TO BEGIN I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO GO OVER THIS
COMPACT WITH THE FAQ AND
RANCHERIA BAND A CHECK CHANCE
THE INDIANS. I'D ALSO LIKE TO
THANK TRIBAL CHAIRPERSON
GONZALEZ WHOSE TIME AND EFFORT
WAS KEY IN FINALIZING THIS
COMPACT. THANK YOU YOUR INJURY
IS CONTACTING CORPORATES MANY
OF THE CHURCH PROVISIONS
TRADITIONALLY INCLUDED IN PRIOR
CONTACTS. IT WAS NEGOTIATED BY
THE GOVERNOR SUBJECT TO
RATIFICATION BY THE LEGISLATURE
IN ACCORDANCE WITH PROP ONE A.
IN THE INDIAN GAMING REGULATORY
ACT. RECENTLY I DISCUSSED WITH
THE COMMITTEE TO OTHER CONTACTS
RATHER THAN REPEAT BACKGROUND
INFORMATION ALL FOCUS ON THE
PROVISIONS THAT ARE UNIQUE OR
SPECIFIC TO PICK YUN RANCHERIA
FOR THIS YEAR. CURRENTLY THE
PICKING OR INJURY OPERATES
NEARLY TWO THOUSAND SLOT
MACHINES THAT EXTRACT CHANTING
GOLD RESORT AND CASINO LOCATED
IN MADERA COUNTY. UNDER THIS
NEW COMPACT THE TRIBE CAN
OPERATE UP TO THIRTY FIVE
HUNDRED GAMING DEVICES. I TRIED
TO MANAGE A PAYING ITS PRO RATA
SHARE OF COST OF THE SPECIAL
DISTRIBUTION FUND WHICH
REIMBURSES THE STATE FOR ITS
REGULATORY AND OTHER DIRECT
COSTS OF GAMING. WHEN IT
OPERATES. OVER THREE THOUSAND
GAMING DEVICES THE TRIBAL
CONTRIBUTE AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ANNUALLY TO
THE US YEAH. THIS HELPS SUPPORT
THE POTENTIAL ELIMINATION OR
REDUCTION OF SPF PRO RATA
PAYMENTS FOR UNLIMITED GAMING
TRIBES. THE PICKING RANCHERIAS
REVENUE SHARING TRUST FUND
PAYMENTS REFLECT ONGOING
COMMITMENT IN A DEMO YOU WITH
MADERA COUNTY TO FINDING LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND FIRE
SERVICES. THE TRIBE WILL MAKE
OUR STF PAYMENTS RANGING FROM
2% IN THAT WHEN OPERATING AT
LEAST THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
GAMING DEVICES. AFTER FIVE AND
A HALF PERCENT AND IT WENT OVER
THREE THOUSAND SLOT MACHINES.
THESE ARE STF PAYMENTS SUPPORT-ANNUAL DISBURSEMENT OF ONE
POINT ONE MILLION. THE NON
GAMING AND MANY GAMING TRIBES
ACCESS ARTIST YOU HAVE FUNDS
ARE ALSO AVAILABLE TO TRIBES
THROUGH GRANTS FROM THE TRIBAL
NATIONS GRANT FUNDS. CONSISTENT
WITH RECENT CONTACTS THE BIG
UNIQUE RANCHERIAS CONTACT AS A
TWENTY FIVE YEAR TERM. IT
ALLOWS THE TRIED TO NEGOTIATE
AN AMENDMENT IF IT'S NOT WINDY
CREASES BY AT LEAST 15% DUE TO
THE OPENING EXTENSION OF
ANOTHER TRIBAL GAMING FACILITY
WITHIN SIXTY MILES. AS IN OTHER
RECENT CONTACTS THAT PICKING
RANCHERIAS CONTACT INCLUDES
LICENSING AND OTHER TERMS TO
HELP INSURE FAIR PLAY AND
HONESTY IN GAMING OPERATIONS
SUCH AS EMPLOYING LICENSING
STANDARDS. THE TRIBES CONTACTS
AS FAR AS HEALTH SAFETY AND
LABOR STANDARDS AS WELL. MINORS
UNDER AGE EIGHTEEN ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO GAME IN THE TRAM
AGREED TO COMPLY WITH MINIMUM
AGE REQUIREMENTS CONSISTENT
WITH STATE LAW FOR TOBACCO AND
ALCOHOL SALES. THE BAKING
RANCHERIA CONTACTING CORPORATES
TRIBAL LAW REQUIREMENTS FOR
PAGING DISPUTES TOWARDS
EMPLOYMENT DISCRIMINATION
CLAIMS. INCORPORATING RATHER
THAN DIRECTING TRAVEL
REQUIREMENTS IS RESPECTFUL OF
THE GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT
NATURE OF THE TRIBAL STATE
RELATIONSHIPS. THE PICKING
RANCHERIA ALSO AGREED TO ENSURE
MINIMUM WAGE RATES AT LEAST AS
STRINGENT AS CALIFORNIANS AND
TO MAINTAIN ITS TRIBAL LABOR
RELATIONS ORDINANCE R. T. L. R.
O. WHICH IS APPENDED TO THE
CONTACT. THE TLR OAK LIES ON
THE DRIVE IN PLACE TWO HUNDRED
AND TWO HUNDRED FIFTY OR MORE
NON TRIBAL MEMBERS IN ITS
GAMING RELATED FACILITIES. THE
TELLER- FUNCTIONS AS THE
MECHANISM FOR A BILATERAL
CONTRACTS BETWEEN THE TRIBE AND
LABOR ORGANIZATIONS. THE LABOR
ORGANIZATION ACCEPTS THE DLR-
THAN THE TRIBE COMMITS TO
BINDING DISPUTE RESOLUTION
INCLUDING FOR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING. IN ADDITION TO THIS
ANOTHER NOW STANDARD DEALER-
PROVISIONS THE PICKING
RANCHERIAS KELLER- INCLUDES
TERMS THAT BENEFIT THE TRIBE
AND LABOR ORGANIZATIONS. THE
DEALER- PREVENTS A LABOR
ORGANIZATION FROM ATTEMPTING TO
ORGANIZE. UNDER THE TAYLOR- FOR
ONE YEAR IF IT ATTEMPTS TO
ORGANIZE UNDER THE NATIONAL
LABOR RELATIONS ACT IF THE
TRIBE OR THE LABOR ORGANIZATION
CAN IT'S AN UNFAIR LABOR
PRACTICE DURING ORGANIZING
CARRYING. THE TRIBE MAY BE
REQUIRED TO AUTOMATICALLY
RECOGNIZE THE UNION WHILE THE
LABOR ORGANIZATIONS ELECTION
COULD BE DELAYED. THE DLR- ALSO
INCLUDES LANGUAGE CLARIFYING
THAT THE TRIBAL LABOR PANEL IS
NOT SPECIFIC TO ONE TRIBE. AND
THAT PARTY IS NOT REQUIRED TO
EXHAUST TRIBAL COURT REMEDIES
TO COMPILER AND FORCE AN
ARBITRATION AWARD. FINALLY IT'S
A SIZE AND PARTY CHALLENGING AN
ARBITRATION AWARD OR THE DUTY
TO ARBITRATE IS LIABLE FOR THE
OTHER PARTY'S ATTORNEYS FEES.
CONSISTENT WITH PRIOR CONCOCTS
THEY'RE PICKING RANCHERIA
COMMITTED TO ROBUST
ENVIRONMENTAL REVEW OF
POTENTIAL OFF RESERVATION
IMPACTS. IF OFF RESERVATION
IMPACTS CANNOT BE AVOIDED OR
FULLY MITIGATED THE TRIBE MUST
COMPLETE A TRIBAL ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT REPORT AND DEVELOP AN
INTER GOVERNMENTAL AGREEMENT
WITH THE LOCAL JURISDICTION. IF
THE TRIBE WILL NOT BE OPERATING
MORE THAN THREE INTERN FORTY
NINE GAMES MAKING USE AN
ALTERNATIVE MEET AND CONFER
PROCESS WITH THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION TO MITIGATE
IMPACTS OF PUBLIC SERVICES.
SPECIFIC TO PICKING RANCHERIA
THE CONTRACT INCLUDES
ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE ANALOGOUS
TO THAT LEVEL TO A LEAD AGENCY
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT. SAYS
FIND APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF
DEFERENCE IN REVIEWING FOR
TRAVEL DECISION. AS FOR PRIOR
RATIFIED CONTACTS. COMPACT
INCLUDES A PROCESS FOR
RESOLVING DISPUTES BETWEEN THE
TRIBE AND THE STATE. IN THE
CASE OF THANK YOU NIGERIA
BEFORE SEEKING TERMINATION OF A
COMPACT. THE PARTY ALLEGING A
BREACH MUST GIVE THE OTHER
PARTY SIXTY DAYS TO CURE AFTER
A FINAL COURT ORDER FINDING
BREACH. HOWEVER THE PROCESS IS
DESIGNED TO ENCOURAGE GOOD
FAITH NEGOTIATIONS TO RESOLVE
ANY DISPUTES CONSISTENT WITH
THE GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT
NATURE OF THE TRIBAL STATE
RELATIONSHIPS. I'D LIKE TO
INVITE AGAIN THANKING THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO GO OVER THE SPECIFIC
PROVISIONS OF THIS COMPACT AND
THE TRIBE IN PARTICULAR FOR ITS
EFFORTS TO REACH AGREEMENT.
I'LL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE I HAVE.
THANKS TO SLOWLY- THAT GIVE THE
CONTACT INCLUDES ADDITIONAL
PAYMENTS TO THE- S. D. F. OF
THE TRIBE OPERATES. MORE THAN
THREE THOUSAND GAMING DEVICES.
WHAT IS THE THINKING THERE AND-
IS THIS UNIQUE TO JUST THIS
CONTACT. IT'S NOT UNIQUE TO
JUSTICE CONTACTS CERTAIN OTHER
TRIBES- LARGE GAMING TRIBES
TEND TO HAVE SOME PROVISIONS
THAT MAY ALLOW FOR ADDITIONAL
PAYMENTS TO THE SDF ABOVE THE
PRO RATA. THE REASONING BEHIND
THAT IS BECAUSE- CONSISTENT
WITH BIGGER- AND RECENT
LEGISLATION PASSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE. WHERE INCLUDING
THESE PROVISIONS TO HELP
ALLOWING FOR LIMITED GAMING
TRIBES TO HAVE THEIR STF
OBLIGATIONS RELIEVED SO THAT
THE- COSTS OF THOSE STF
PAYMENTS TO THE EXTENT
POSSIBLE- CAN BE SHARED AMONGST
SOME OF THE LARGER GAMING
TRIBES TO HELP BETTER
DISTRIBUTE THE- REVENUE AND-
BENEFITS OF TRIBAL GAMING.
THANK YOU- IN. I REALLY
APPRECIATE- YEAH THE LAST
COUPLE TIMES WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
WORK TOGETHER AS WELL IF I
MIGHT SAY- MISS NAME MARK IS-
FORTUNATE THAT SHE HAS YOU-
WHEN SHE'S OUT YOU'VE DONE A
GREAT JOB FOR SHEET THAT- RIGHT
NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO.
CLAUDIA GONZALEZ THE TRIBAL
CHAIR FOR THE PICU. RANCHERIA I
BELIEVE SHE IS ALSO ON ZOOM
CHAIRWOMAN. PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING MORNING. GOOD
MORNING. CHAIRING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CLAUDIA
GONZALEZ AND I'M THE CHAIRMAN
OF THE PEAK UNIVERSE REACTOR
CHANCE THE INDIANS. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN GOTTEN SENATOR BOARD
JUST FOR AGREEING TO AUTHOR SQ
THREE R. TWO. ALSO THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME THE TIME TO
PROVIDE SOME BRIEF REMARKS
TODAY. THIS COMPACT THAT IS
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY
REPRESENTS A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF WORK. BOTH BY THE STATE AND
OUR TRIBAL COUNCIL. WE WANT TO
THANK GOVERNOR NEWSOM IS
TROUBLE NEGOTIATOR. AND NATHAN
FOR DEVOTING. TIME DURING THE
DIFFICULTIES THAT THE CODE
NINETEEN CONDIMENT PRESENT IT.
TO GAIN CONSENSUS ON A NUMBER
OF ISSUES. WE WORK TOWARDS WHAT
HAS BECOME A MUTUALLY.
BENEFICIAL AGREEMENT. K. HAS
BEEN THE TO THE ECONOMIC. OF
THE FIJIAN RANCHERIA FOR
SEVERAL DECADES. WE ARE PROUD
OF OUR CHANCE TO GOLD RESORT
AND CASINO. WHICH HAS BECOME AN
OPERATION SINCE TWO THOUSAND
THREE. AND IT IS LOCATED IN OUR
SCHOOLS MADERA COUNTY. OUR GOAL
ENTERING INTO THIS CONTRACT IS
TO PROVIDE CERTAINTY FOR THE
FUTURE OF OUR TRIBE. THAT IS
IMPORTANT AS WE CONTINUE TO
STRIVE TO PROVIDE EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE COMMUNITY.
AND MAINTAIN CONTINUOUS
OPERATIONS. ECONOMIC
ENTERPRISES THAT BECOME CRUCIAL
TO OUR MEMBERS. THE ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY PROVIDED TO OUR
TRIBE IN SURROUNDING COMMUNITY.
HAS BCOME EVEN MORE VITAL AS
WE FACE THE CHALLENGES INDUCED
BY THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
DURING THE PANDEMIC WE HAVE
IMPLEMENTED AN ENHANCED HEALTH
STANDARDS. FOR THE SAFETY OF
OUR PATRONS EMPLOYEES WE EMPLOY
OVER ELEVEN HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS
ACROSS OUR RESORT AND CASINO
OPERATIONS AND ARE ONE OF THE
LARGEST EMPLOYERS IN THE REGION.
OUR RESORT AND CASINO HAS DONE
MORE THAN JUST PROVIDE ECONOMIC
ENGINE FOR TRIBAL MEMBERS. AND
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY WE HAVE
ALSO SERVED AS SAFE HAVEN
DURING THE NATURAL DISASTERS.
DURING THE CREEK FIRE WE WERE
ABLE TO HOUSE NUMEROUS FAMILIES
SEEKING SHELTER AND WORK
CLOSELY WITH FEDERAL AND STATE
OFFICIALS TO ENSURE. THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO BASIC NECESSITIES.
THIS NEW COMPACT WILL ALLOW US
TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL HEALTH EDUCATION.
ECONOMIC PROGRAMS AND OTHER
SERVICES YOUR TRAVEL COMMUNITY.
AT THE SAME TIME THE CONTACT
PROVIDES BENEFITS TO THE STATE
PROTECTION STORE EMPLOYEES AND
CUSTOMERS OF THE LARGER MADERA
COUNTY COMMUNITY. OVER THE
YEARS YEMEN HAS ENJOYED A
STRONG RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR
LOCAL LEADERS AND WE HAVE HAD A
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING
WITH THE COUNTY MADERA SINCE
TWO THOUSAND AND ONE. IN THE MO
YOU THE COUNTY AND THE TRIBE
HAVE A LONGSTANDING AGREEMENT
ON ISSUES RELATED TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT SERVICES. FIRE
PROTECTION SERVICES. TRAFFIC
AND ROAD MAINTENANCE AND WATER
AND SEWER SUPPORT. AS WELL AS
JOBS AND SOCIAL SERVICES THE
TRIBE HAS ALSO AGREED TO
INCREASE THE LEVEL OF FINANCIAL
SUPPORT TO PROVIDE THE COUNTY
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT. FIRE
PROTECTION SERVICES. FINALLY WE
WANT TO PUBLICLY STATE THAT WE
HONOR AND SUPPORT OUR T. L. R.
L. AND THEN WE'VE ENJOYED A
POSITIVE WORKING RELATIONSHIP
WITH LABOR FOR ALMOST TWO
DECADES. IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FOUR THE KEY IN ANY NIGHT HERE
EXECUTED AT COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT AND IT HAS
REMAINED IN PLACE EVER SENT.
ONCE AGAIN I APPRECIATE BEING
ABLE TO BRIEF YOU ON OUR
CONTACT. AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST LEGISLATOR RADHA PICKY
AND COMPACT WITH THE STATE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH YOUR WOMAN REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE- HARD WORK
ON YOUR TRIBE'S BEHALF THAT
DONE AND- KEEP THE GOOD
NEGOTIATIONS AND GONE FORWARD
HERE. NOW WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM
MARIO YOU DD UP- FROM THE WEST
HE'S A WESTERN REGIONAL
POLITICAL DIRECTOR FOR UNITE
HERE I BELIEVE HE IS ALSO ON.
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN DOT AND
MEMBERS- GOOD MORNING TO
CHAIRWOMAN CONSOLIDATES AND MR
BOLDLY AT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE. THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS YOU. MY
NAME IS MARIO. AND THE WESTERN
REGIONAL POLITICAL DIRECTOR
WITH UNITE HERE INTERNATIONAL
UNION FOR THE HOSPITALITY
WORKERS UNION. IN NORTH AMERICA
R. THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
MEMBERS ARE OVERWHELMINGLY
PEOPLE OF COLOR IMMIGRANTS AND
WOMEN. IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE
PROUD THAT SEVEN THOUSAND I
MUST WORK NINE TRIBAL CASINOS
ACROSS THE STATE. WHERE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS ENSURE DIGNITY
RESPECT AND FAIR WAGES AND
BENEFITS THIS MORNING WE ARE
ENTHUSIASTICALLY PROUD TO
SUPPORT THE NEW COMPACT BETWEEN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
THE PECAN RANCHERIA CHANCY
INDIANS OF CALIFORNIA- THE
CHANCE TO GOLD RESORT CASINO
OWNED BY THE PRC I MAINTAIN THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
WITH NIGHTS HERE. LOCAL NINETY
AS MISS GONZALEZ SPOKE TO- THAT
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
GUARANTEES FAIR WAGES STEADY
RAISES AN AFFORDABLE VISION
DENTAL AND HEALTH INSURANCE WE
DEEPLY VALUE AS WELL OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE CHUCK
CHANCY GOLD RESORT CASINO. AND
A QUALITY JOBS THERE WE THANK
THE GOVERNOR FOR NEGOTIATING
THIS CONTRACT AND WE ASK THAT
THE LEGISLATURE PLEASE APPROVE.
IT WITHOUT DELAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER YOU HERE- NOW
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. IS THERE ANYONE HERE
IN THE GALLERY WHICH IS TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC TESTIMONY- SEE
NOBODY IN THE GALLERY AND
MOVING ON TO ROOM TWELVE ONE
TWELVE NOT SEEING ANYTHING
THERE. WE NOW WE'LL MOVE ON TO
ANYONE WAITING TO- TESTIFIED
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS.
MODERATOR GOOD MORNING IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO PLEASE PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
WE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU MR
JACK. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
A PUBLIC COMMENT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT
ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT. AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
DOT IN A COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS AMBER MOHAMMED ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA. ON
THE PHONE TODAY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU KNOW THE
REMINDER TO ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR ANY PUBLIC COMMENT. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
OKAY THANK YOU A MODERATOR I
WANT TO PERSONALLY THANK
EVERYBODY THAT- PRESENTED
TODAY- AND THANK YOU FOR BEING
ON BOARD HERE MODERATOR- ONCE
AGAIN THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS- DID THAT MADE THIS
HAPPEN AS A REMINDER IF YOU ARE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS. OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING THE
SENATE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE OR VISIT
OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE VISUAL HEARING
RECORD. THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
THE SENATE- GOVERNMENTAL.
COMMITTEE SAID THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS IS
ADJOURNED.